in the case of the brain you know you
just organized thinking but we don't
know what thinking is so you can't look
us and same ones it's not thinking right
so we didn't come to you know in will
chance to fight back against cancer
until we do the facing they say laws by
which DNA operated and then finally how
chromosomes divide etc and all those
details once we had that then we could
get to ask well why does the cancer cell
behave differently the case of the brain
it's clearly so complicated that in
reality about the only people who think
about the brain or outsiders who not
capable understanding it this is people
who are sort of bright enough or you
know trained enough know how I would
have the complex of this and know
Francis Crick spent 20 years trying to
think about it if the end another came
out of it so there's some perverse way I
think the only people really know who
should think about how the brain
operates are those people who deal with
schizophrenia or bipolar disease when
you know they the brain just sitting you
know it doesn't work so because
for the most part the people who study
it you only got into the field because
they have a child or they have a sister
or brother you know you read it because
you want to cure someone and so we can
take away delusions from people with
schizophrenia but they're very
cognitively impaired we don't know how
to Richard who repaired the cognition
defects that's why they become homeless
if there's no one taking care of them
they just really can't look after
themselves so you know the thoughts that
you can teach the homeless to take care
of themselves now we have to take care
of them
yes I have a son who is a non-driver
former schizophrenia but really cannot
take care of himself and the great fear
of that of all parents is when the
parents die who takes care of your child
and the answers they become homeless you
know unless there's sufficient money in
the family or something but given the
structure of society today remember
you're treated very cruelly
we sort of deny their existence
Congress had virtually no interest in
greater interest in cancer was no
interest no one wants to hold a hearing
I would say predisposition 100% where
they progresses to full-blown
schizophrenia probably some
environmental influences such as it's
clear if you're predisposed to
schizophrenia smoking marijuana is will
tip you over but marijuana won't tip
over someone then the schizophrenia is
probably not predisposed so you know
most people smoke it and you know I do
not end up in mental hospitals but some
do
we serve propose you know sequencing a
hundred thousand and mentally ill people
because it's not going to be just one
gene that you need to stop a car from
functioning by you know just drawing a
large number of different parts and the
same way you can sort of keep put the
brain big of risk functional by just
destroying one small part of a whole
operating system so well we're pretty
sure they're in least hunters of genes
but we think we've put together there
will be some pathway this schizophrenia
about which we can intervene in some
cases and it's too complicated for me
now to to say but it may be even though
many genes are in drought the way the
brain works based nonetheless the
neighbor was to cure some some cases of
autism what just look because hopeless
is anything if the people have a
abnormally high temperature and they are
in fever their symptoms diminish now so
you think well you know just raise their
temperature a couple of degrees and they
will be so sick we're in fact the name
of meeting about this so I'm dominated
you know I walked it we have to get the
genetic information but as parent I want
something good to happen you know over
the next five to ten years